essere conosciuti su internet triplica
delle complicazioni complicazioni di
livello estremo perché nel caso non lo
sapeste esistono immagina che cos'è
un'immagina qualcuno anzi meglio
qualcuna prevalentemente di età compresa
dai 10 ai 14 anni ha ricavato fuori
questa moda dell'immagina circa 4 34
anni fa che cos'è non vorrebbe saperlo
ma lo zio fa vive lo spiega l'immagina
sono delle storielle erotiche inventate
da quella fascia di persone che ho
specificato poco prima su di me e te
loro bene loro quindi speriamo che non
mi facciano outing in questo momento gli
apriamo un po a caso e vediamo che cosa
troviamo la mia vita avrà una fine prima
o poi perdiamo il primo molto non lo so
in realtà o per turno a caso l'immagine
su fuori gente seria scuola ha il ciclo
6 eccitate voi scoprire quindi vai da un
ragazzo più figo della scuola lorenzo
eccolo sicuramente gli tiri la manica
della camicia e lo porti in un'aula
vuota conti i puntini da cinquantenni
dopo un po vi sfogliate è sempre quella
parola lì che non posso dire però
purtroppo non avevi non so se questo
video riuscire a venderlo fermi friendly
ragazzi è molto difficile
purtroppo non avevi portati i
preservativi per lorenzo dopo alcuni
giorni se rimasta incinta
così ha imparato che un pene di 54 ai
ragazzi ma così poco pensate da che un
pene la c30 l'attrice non era da
sottovalutare e vissero tutti felici e
contenti fine al non solo e questo è un
pregio
spero di sì perché molti erano serie
allora la cosa è degenerata quindi da
che tutti erano seri
c'era qualche pranks o diventati tutti
prank il altane stesso tutti fake
immagina da rainbow room channel fan di
j con la scritta classi tagliola 6 a
scuola manca la prof di italiano allora
arriva una supplente che dice ragazzi
fate quello che volete ma a bassa voce
mamma mia bellissima questa allora tu ti
metti a parlare con lorenzo quello che
ti piace e parlate delle persone che
nella vostra classe pro ii devono
spiegare a questa ragazza che semmai a
capo non devi mettere per forza alla
maiuscola deve pensare che fa questa
classe potevo stare bene insieme ad un
certo punto ti chiede sai quale altra
coppia potrebbe essere perfetta no
rispondi tu allora 20 si avvicina e ti
bacia totalmente a caso ma ok ora siete
fidanzati vero kringe signori immagina
24 una qualità pessima tutte ste robe
per ok tu e lorenzo siete bollino rosso
tensione lorenzo siete fidanzati da
parecchi mesi ormai deciso di fare un
passo avanti lo re punti e da un po di
tempo che ti devo dire una cosa
una cosa l dimmi tu ti andrebbe di fare
un passo avanti dice abbassando di un po
la cerniera lui era il sito di colpo l
ovvero te la dò la password del mio
profilo facebook sei alla festa del tuo
amico lorenzo dopo la festa non sapevi
come andartene perché era molto tardi
lewis si offre di accompagnarti a casa
mai nella vita state tranquilli che
accompagna alla porta vi saluta tema ad
un certo punto ti bacia e ti porta sul
letto io non ho capito un cazzo
nel senso cosa succede ti accoglie non è
fisica questa guarda che l'accompagna
alla porta
vi saluta tema non certo punto ti bacia
e ti porta sul letto ma è casa tua e
casa dura la polizia devi chiamare non
ha senso questa cosa però fa niente non
glielo spieghiamo neanche il bollino
rosso e tondo perfettamente questa cosa
mi dà fastidio
il tuo amico lorenzo siede sul divano
sul tuo divano a guardare un film a un
certo punto i protagonisti si baciano e
tu sei e ti senti in imbarazzo e di
volti che ha visto avere i campi e l'ora
e lo nota e ti prende il mente per farti
votare non sentirsi in imbarazzo piccola
subito dopo ti prende il viso e ti bacia
nel momento stesso in cui avviene del
film immagina con una grafica tipo
gazzetta dello sport del 1950 andiamo
avanti 2 lorenzo stati insieme da ormai
qualche mese
lui decide di venire a trovarti in casa
perché gli manchi a casa tua non ci sono
i tuoi genitori perché sono al lavoro
appena entrati guarda negli occhi dice
non sai quanto ti voglio con questa
questo perché poi mi immagino che loro
sì che si immaginino che io abbia una
voce del tipo non lo so neanche fare
tipo non sai quanto ti voglio
riprovo riprovo perché ci vuole un po di
non sai quanto non quanto e kringe
questo video port cup di baciatevi
toccata vicenda b toccate a vicenda
finché lui non apre la cerniera dito il
jeans ti amo sussurra quell'estate la
vostra prima volta ok la mia prima volta
non mi viene anche alzato però andiamo
avanti ragazzi andiamo avanti queste
sono sono bazzecole immagina verte senza
neanche il bollino perché siamo pigri
brava
tu sei la mia ragazza ideale se al
compleanno del tuo amico pietro già
partiamo da cani e vedi questo ragazzo
che ti guarda e ti fa un sorriso poi si
avvicina e si presenta piacere lorenzo e
tutti presenti pure chiacchierate un po
e vi scambiate il numero di telefono
dopo un po che vi sentite uscite lori ti
bacia il giorno più bello della tua vita
fan page su di te il tatuaggio di lory
che problemi hai porca trota immagina
rosso finalmente uno rosso avevo bisogno
il mio stomaco e già di là se ad una
festa con il tuo amico lorenzo e tra
vicolo esco dalla franzoni in tre
secondi nell'immagine tu devi andare in
bagno così vi si offre di mostrarti dove
quando entrate lui ti sbatte contro il
muro ed inizia a baciarti con foga e
passione andiamo avanti tu lorenzo
piccolo dice togliendoti investito ma ci
sentiranno non così però non riesco ad
esistere tutto basta che non ti dice con
il sorrisetto malizioso attività è tutto
così la mia vita fa schifo sei con tuo
marito lorenzo e tuo figlio appena nato
è l'ora di allattarlo e tu sei pronta
per dall imponente latte materno ma in
quel momento lorenzi entra in camera e
ti dice ehi piccola voglio anche io
essere allattato ti fa l'occhiolino
attesa questa è una chat di whatsapp
bellissima ti piace prendere
l'iniziativa ea questo sono io te lo
scrivo a lei lori sono io che scrivo ok
ti piace per l'iniziativa è tranquilla
la prossima volta non farò niente farei
tutto te voglio proprio vedere cosa mi
farai potrei stare sul mi attrezzo di
marmo avanti signori
passiamo all'ultima proprio per coronare
tutto queste immagina bollino rosso il
bollino è fatto bene immagina di essere
il gatto di lorenzo
e che lui ti coccoli ogni giorno dormito
nello stesso letto giocate lui pulisce i
tuoi bisogni ma questo non sarà l'ultimo
perché l'ultimo signori cliccate dagli
scriventi schiacciata la campanella per
il rimanere aggiornati sui noi video
escono nel mettere leggiamo l'ultimo
anche il tasto mi piace serve a questo
ragazzi schiacciatelo in questo momento
e noi andiamo sulla lettura dell'ultimo
6 in prima media arrapata come una
troppe di parigi con la j maiuscola in
ricreazione gli offre il suo panino col
prosciutto lui lo butta a terra dicendo
vada via al cell
poi ti sbatte al muro e ti tira trash un
allucinante
[Musica]